- [Narrator] Let's get some practice
with our exponent properties,
especially when we have integer exponents.
So, let's think about what
four to the negative three
times four to the fifth power
is going to be equal to.
And I encourage you to pause the video
and think about it on your own.
Well there's a couple of ways to do this.
See look, I'm multiplying two things
that have the same base,
so this is going to be that base, four.
And then I add the exponents.
Four to the negative three plus five power
which is equal to four
to the second power.
And that's just a straight
forward exponent property,
but you can also think about
why does that actually make sense.
Four to the negative 3 power,
that is one over four to the third power,
or you could view that as
one over four times four times four.
And then four to the fifth,
that's five fours being
multiplied together.
So it's times four times four
times four times four times four.
And so notice, when you multiply this out,
you're going to have five
fours in the numerator
and three fours in the denominator.
And so, three of these in the denominator
are going to cancel out
with three of these in the numerator.
And so you're going to be left
with five minus three,
or negative three plus five fours.
So this four times four
is the same thing as four squared.
Now let's do one with variables.
So let's say that you have
A to the negative fourth power
times A to the,
let's say, A squared.
What is that going to be?
Well once again, you have the same base,
in this case it's A, and so
since I'm multiplying them,
you can just add the exponents.
So it's going to be A to the
negative four plus two power.
Which is equal to A to
the negative two power.
And once again, it should make sense.
This right over here,
that is one over A times A times A times A
and then this is
times A times A,
so that cancels with that,
that cancels with that,
and you're still left
with one over A times A,
which is the same thing as
A to the negative two power.
Now, let's do it with some quotients.
So, what if I were to ask you,
what is 12 to the negative seven
divided by 12 to the negative five power?
Well, when you're dividing,
you subtract exponents if
you have the same base.
So, this is going to be equal
to 12 to the negative seven
minus negative five power.
You're subtracting the bottom exponent
and so, this is going to
be equal to 12 to the,
subtracting a negative is the same thing
as adding the positive,
twelve to the negative two power.
And once again, we just
have to think about,
why does this actually make sense?
Well, you could actually rewrite this.
12 to the negative seven
divided by 12 to the negative five,
that's the same thing as
12 to the negative seven
times 12 to the fifth power.
If we take the reciprocal
of this right over here,
you would make exponent positive
and then you would get
exactly what we were doing
in those previous examples with products.
And so, let's just do one more
with variables for good measure.
Let's say I have X to the
negative twentieth power
divided by X to the fifth power.
Well once again, we have the same base
and we're taking a quotient.
So, this is going to be X to
the negative 20 minus five
cause we have this one right
over here in the denominator.
So, this is going to be equal
to X to the negative twenty-fifth power.
And once again, you could
view our original expression
as X to the negative twentieth
and having an X to the
fifth in the denominator
dividing by X to the fifth
is the same thing as multiplying
by X to the negative five.
So here you just add the exponents
and once again you would get
X to the negative twenty-fifth power.